- Rectangle 1 is blank meters
blank than Rectangle 2.
Let's look at this.
Rectangle 1 has a width of 3 meters.
Rectangle 2 has a width of 9 meters.
Rectangle 1 is, if you compare 3 to 9,
it's going to be 6 meters shorter.
6 meters shorter than Rectangle 2.
You see that right over here,
because 3 meters is 6 less than 9 meters.
It's 6 meters,
and you know it's not going to be longer.
Rectangle 1 is definitely ...
it has less width.
It's definitely shorter than Rectangle 2.
It's 6 meters shorter than Rectangle 2.
Let's do a few more of these.
Line 1 is blank centimeters long.
We can measure it.
We could measure it right over here.
Line 1 is 9 centimeters long.
9 centimeters long.
Line 2 is blank centimeters long.
Let me actually zoom this in a little bit
so that we can see it a little bit better.
Line 2 is blank centimeters long.
Line 2 is 5 centimeters long.
Let me zoom in a little bit more even.
Line 1 is blank centimeters
blank than Line 2.
Well, Line 1 is 9 verses 5,
so it's 4 centimeters longer than Line 2.
Line 1 is 4 centimeters
longer than Line 2.
You can see it right over here.
To go from Line 2 to Line 1,
you'd have to add 1, 2, 3, 4 centimeters.
Let's do a few more of these.
Triangle 1 is blank centimeters long.
We can just use a ruler to measure
that it's 3 centimeters long.
Triangle 2 is blank centimeters long.
Let me scroll down to look at Triangle 2.
Triangle 2 is 5 centimeters long.
Triangle 1 is blank centimeters
blank than Triangle 2.
Well, Triangle 1 is 2 centimeters
shorter than Triangle 2.
3 is 2 less than 5.
It's going to be 2 centimeters shorter.
Remember, Triangle 1, we see it's shorter
it's smaller than Triangle 2,
so it makes since that it's shorter.
How much shorter?
2 centimeters because 3 centimeters
compared to 5 centimeters.
Let's do one more of these.
Rectangle 1 is blank centimeters long.
We can just look right over here.
It's 9 centimeters long.
We have one end of the ruler
at one end of the rectangle,
and then we just measure
off 9 centimeters.
Rectangle 2 is, well,
it looks like it's 6 centimeters long.
6 centimeters long.
Rectangle 1 is longer,
and it's 3 centimeters
longer than Rectangle 2.
9 centimeters is 3 centimeters
more than 6 centimeters.
It's 3 centimeters longer.
Rectangle 1 is the longer Rectangle.
Then, we're done.